my name is Sonia sama and I am a student
here at the GSB the completed three
years in medical school and I'm here at
the GSB to complete two years of Mandya
my interest in medicine stems from the
values that my parents instilled within
me as members of the Sikh faith the idea
of Java and selfless service drew me
towards a profession like medicine my
interest in global health was really
sparked by this idea of health and
innovation as president the GSB in the
Center for social innovation I aimed it
with the professor who led the course
essentially what he did is he brought in
surgeons from around the world to tell
us about all the amazing things they
were doing either leper colonies in
India or cataract surgery in Africa and
I thought to myself is something I
absolutely want to do too and so he and
I organized our first trip to Mexico
where we helped another group of
surgeons treat cleft lip and palate and
burn victims what this professor I
started the nonprofit Global Health
volunteers in founding Global Health
volunteers and going to medical school I
realized that my long-term goal is to
become CEO of a non-profit and
international health and medicine in
order to run an organization effectively
I needed a tool set to do so more
importantly a business school tool set
that Stanford GSB in particular
cultivated in
we're on the campus that has so many
different disciplines there are a lot of
opportunities to combine my medicine
background and a new business skillset
the motto of Stanford Business School is
change lives change organizations and
change the world and I realized that
that's what I wanted to do with Phil the
health volunteers and come into Stanford
to really give me the toolkit to be able
to become an effective leader to create
an organization that really did change
lives and change the world in the area
of international health and medicine
you